I call what's going on with kids
grooming
okay so let's define what grooming is
grooming is the emotional and
psychological manipulation of a
vulnerable person with the goal of
exploiting them in some way in the
future
there is sexual grooming there is
financial grooming
and there is ideological grooming
now I believe that with all of our
sexuality education and gender education
there is no doubt in my mind that there
is sexual and ideological grooming
that's going on
and I'll explain a very simple thing to
you
you see if you have a four or five year
old
uh and they're in a preschool group
and the page and the um the teacher
begins to discuss
um
uh anatomically correct names for the
body
and this is a this is a huge thing you
know in in sex education that these
little kids need to know
uh penis and vulva and clitoris and
testicles like they all need to know
they shouldn't be using childish names
for those parts of their bodies oh no no
no no no that's a bad thing they need to
know the the terms the actual terms
but you see when that's begins
what happens
the message that the child is given a
is that
we can talk about these very private
things
at school
we should not feel a sense of
embarrassment if we feel a drop of
embarrassment we need to deny that
the teachers talking about these things
she or he feels very comfortable talking
about a penis and a vulva and a clitoris
I should also be comfortable with all my
classmates around me boys girls with
this teacher that I may have just met
two weeks ago
I'm supposed to feel comfortable
so that's called desensitization
and that is
the beginning of Grooming
because in order to groom somebody that
person has to feel comfortable with you
and has to trust you
so when our sex educators are telling us
as they have been for so long
that these little kids need to learn
they're anatomically correct words for
their bodies and I'm that's only the
beginning I mean they're telling them
about
uh you know anal sex by the time they're
10 years old but let's put that aside
so it's a form of Grooming
um it's a form of at such a young age
the child is supposed to deny their
inborn sense of
shame or embed let's say embarrassment
that's a normal sense of embarrassment
that should be there
that's what I'm arguing we want our kids
to have that
and the other message that the kids get
from the teacher from that whole thing
of being of teach of learning those
words and talking about genitals
is they get the message that it's not at
home that I'm going to learn about these
things it's not my parents that are the
experts that I need to go to for my
questions it's my school it's my teacher
when a child
has has internalized that message of I
can trust this person this adult
um I it's not at home that we discuss
these issues I have to
um I I have to deny my internal
discomfort that is is gr is making that
child more available for inappropriate
sexual behavior
that's how I'm tying this into the
pedophilia does that work for you
yes but I I'm I mean it does and I get
what you're saying and it's a very good
point but I was looking at it more most
in the case of if we look back at it
historically a lot of people who have
propagated and created these theories
there is a link is there not or am I or
am I misrepresenting or simply incorrect
there is a link and there's the the link
is to uh uh destroy any uh any remnant
of any judeo-christian morality in our
society and that's a part of it
um you know the sexual morality part of
it and and again people like John money
uh uh Alfred Kinsey that who we didn't
discuss They promoted also a pedophile
they want to promote the idea that we
are all sexual from Cradle to grave so
if children are sexual well then why are
we preventing them from engaging in
sexual behavior as adults I mean adults
are who love them what's wrong with that
so it's all part of destroying the
morality that so yes I agree with you
there is a link there is a real link
foreign